bon ben bonjour je suis ravie passé un
court moment avec vous vraiment pour
qu'on puisse s'interroger ensemble
yat-il encore moyen de se rebeller
dans une société capitaliste néolibéral
alors bon si on considère que une
société capitaliste néolibéral une de
ses caractéristiques principales
c'est cette faculté qu elle a à tout
absorber tout récupérer tous formatés ne
suis d'ailleurs pas ici en train de vous
parler de rebellions sous le label tedx
liège pour illustrer mon propos je
voudrais prendre en exemple que tout le
monde connaît une figure emblématique le
che guevara bon ben le che guevara qui
pour le coup n'est pas un rebelle
c'était une véritable icône
révolutionnaire
le che guevara aujourd'hui on peut le
voir sur des t-shirts et même même sur
des paquets de cigarettes alors
bah dans une société capitaliste
néolibéral absolument tout tous sans
exception devient une marchandise
alors malgré cette étape fait est ce que
le hip hop est une forme de rébellion
dans une société capitaliste néolibéral
alors le hip hop je dois expliquer un
peu succès 1 pour ceux qui savent pas
donc le hip hop ces quatre disciplines
c'est le graffiti mais je pense que
j'abats en parlera mieux que moi tout à
l'heure c'est le big bang la danse
breakdance et puis c'est le rap l'art du
m6 donc le rap qu'est ce que c'est
basset s'est scandé des rimes sur une
rythmique particulière alors je propose
qu'on s'attache plus spécifiquement aura
puisque c'est la discipline que j'ai
choisi ya plus de 25 ans maintenant
qu'est ce que c'est que le rap
you j'entends ouais ça je vais vous dire
j'ai quarante trois ans et on fait
toujours you un peu fatiguant parfois
enfin bon le rap en fait si on remonte à
ses origines et à ses racines
eh ben on doit aller jusqu'en afrique
parce qu'en afrique il ya une vraie
tradition de la culture de l'oralité et
notamment chez chez les griots alors la
fonction sociale du griot c'était de
passer d'un village à l'autre et
transmettre des messages de raconter des
histoires et puis bon vous n'êtes pas
sans ignorer qu'il ya eu l'esclavagé
quatre siècles de déportation quand même
et la plupart des historiens parlent
quand même 200 millions mort 100
millions et donc avec l' esclavage la
tradition de l'oralité a franchi
l'atlantique et on la retrouve dans les
champs de coton par exemple alors je
propose qu'on fasse ensemble à bonds
dans le temps et dans l'espace et on se
retrouve à new york dans les années 60
où apparaît le premier véritable groupe
de rap qui s'appelle de la ce poète et
donc les last poets ben il faut se
remettre dans le contexte de l'époque
c'est la guerre du vietnam il ya tous
les mouvements afro américains
révolutionnaire qui se met en place
comme les black panthers comme malcolm x
et donc que bâle et l'as poète c'est un
peu un instantané de cette époque là un
instantané de la réalité des jeunesses
afro-américaine des quartiers pauvres
donc je vous ai déjà parlé en peu de
temps de la société néolibérale du
hip-hop et du rap
alors ya le rap d'un côté et puis à moi
ou pourquoi je m'appelle l'enfant avait
alors mis vers 1984 assez curieusement
sur tf1 il ya eu la première émission
entièrement consacrée au hip hop qui
s'appelait d'ailleurs a chipé à choper
présenté par sidney est là dans l'écran
pour la première fois de ma vie j'ai vu
des gars qui me ressemble et quoi est ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui pudiquement
des jeunes issus de la diversité et donc
chaque semaine j'apprenais des pas de
cette nouvelle dans ce qui s'appelait le
breakdance et pour moi ça a été un choc
terrible
les débuts vraiment d'une réelle passion
qui m'anime toujours aujourd'hui
voilà pourquoi je m'appelle l'enfant
pavé ce n'est pas le nom que j'ai reçu
c'est le nom que j'ai choisi alors
souvent quand je dis à des enfants vous
savez comment je m'appelle moi je
m'appelle enfants pavé ils se marient
banon soit un adulte
là non je m'appelle l'enfant pas vrai ce
n'est pas un nom que j'ai reçu c'est le
nom j'ai choisi alors pour vous parler
de ce nom que j'ai choisi je suis obligé
de faire un peu de généalogie
mon grand père était ouvrier
chauffagiste à la ville de liège et
lutter à ses heures
ma grand-mère était orpheline ma mère
était bibliothécaire c'est sûrement elle
qui m'a transmis l'amour des livres et
des mots mon père était un métis
africain qui a grandi jusqu'à l'âge de 4
ans dans une case au congo moment où mon
grand-père ce militaire austère de
carrière a décidé qu'il était temps de
ramener depuis l'autre bout de la terre
ce morceau par solaire de son génome
identitaire et me voici qui
bar sur cette vaste terre très vite mon
pater à voguer vers d'autres mères bon à
part cet incident majeur et puis
peut-être cette fois aussi aux mon grand
père a fait une angine de poitrine dans
la rue de joie avec moi dans la
poussette en train de me pousser dans la
poussette un s'invente pas un art eu de
joie angine de poitrine mois dans un
poussette et bien à ce fut une enfant
sans histoire mais écoutons là je vous
la donne à voir ou plutôt non à écouter
et comme je dis toujours je suis surpris
d'être toujours vivant
1 et vers 2001 on disait même survivant
pour moi ça continue d'être sur un
surprenant
ok l'enfant dis-moi dis-moi sécu sur le
pif
vibra dis-moi dis-moi sais qui sur le
moment
dis-moi dis-moi dis-moi ainsi qui sur le
coup
dis-moi dis-moi dis-moi si qui souleva
la belge est trop peine à parler du
passé il paraît que tout ce passe en 0-6
ans tout est joué et le destin faisant
la vie passe en vieillissant peu de
repères comme un gamin très vite la pub
de la rue de ces chemins des cendres de
nos colis pour le coeur de la ville trop
de choses pour nos autres gosses à
l'époque le shit était déjà saint amand
punis puis leurs emplettes arrive tu
sais on ça finit dur pour ma mère à la
maison cela n'est pas propre un fils et
notre survie
elle a fait son maximum et je suis
devenu un homme et au microphone je
reste dix mois a dit laura dis moi si je
veux vivre
dis-moi dis-moi séguy sur le banc
dis-moi dis-moi dis-moi cki sur le pays
dis moi vivent dix mois ci qui sur le
g10 grandi sans père il avait laissé
traîner sans fils pourtant quand je
regarde en arrière j'ai évité les pires
précipice tenu tête aux mauvaises
fréquentations à la tentation des pires
vices tous complices au début car la
défense quant à pas grand chose est un
but puis très vite l'argent s'ils visent
puis plus rien ne compte
j'ai vu ça faisait quand la gamme dedans
comme un perpétuel
tadam je blâme mais une personne me
plains de rien personne je constate en
personne je jette un regard sur ce que
la mémoire d'homme d'enflammer sur rod
ya du bon du moins bon compte toujours
des solutions
toujours sans effraction derrière chaque
enfant il ya une mère et son affection
souffrent les parents font défection
temps sont dits tous et faisons
attention à leurs dix mois
mathurin violence nous sommes des
enfants
les pavés se retourne et pousse dans
dedans je suis désolé donc je vais
revenir en arrière mais vous l'avez déjà
entendu en fait donc voilà pourquoi
est-ce que je m'appelle l'enfant pavés
c'est à cause de la plus magnifique de
léo ferré
vous connaissez l'eau ferrer qui a écrit
ça dans un de ses morceaux aux mathurins
violence nous sommes des enfants
les paris se retourne et pousse dans
dedans eh bien je pense que si j'avais
une définition à donner de la rébellion
je pense que je donnerais exactement la
même que léo ferré à la différence que
je suis un jeu qui les force à la
violence je suis ton enfin le pavé se
retourne et % de garant je crois qu'il y
a dans mon nom dans le nom que j'ai
choisi beaucoup mais vraiment beaucoup
de rebellions et d'ailleurs finalement
ce nom je les choisis dans un contexte
complètement différent de celui du hip
hop va avoir 17 18 ans et vous savez
quoi
j'ai fait partie de la cia n'ont pas
l'âge
ans gouvernementale américaine cia pour
collectif d'interventions artistiques
old man 2 schmeer bonzes et des
happenings des performances un tas de
trucs notamment à berlin
ici aucune star aux tacles de berlin en
91 1
ces mois là sur la photo ça c'était à
berlin puis ça c'était à liège ruche
merlin gnu old douche mer
et puis un jour avec mes compagnons
d'art on s'est retrouvé dans une
camionnette et on sait chacun donné des
surnoms alors il y avait l'inconnu il y
avait le docteur de rares vins il y
avait soeur à boni mer des charniers à
l'abandon et il y avait moi l'enfant
paraît bon après ça j'ai fait des études
au conservatoire et pour l'anecdote
c'est très drôle parce que j'ai passé
mon examen d'entrée au conservatoire
juste ici en dessous il ya plus de vingt
ans après au conservatoire j'ai eu la
chance de travailler sur des classiques
comme molière marivaux ou encore
shakespeare et puis après des
productions professionnelles comme blood
iniguez mis en scène par jacques
delcuvellerie et le groupe of une espèce
de résumer non exhaustive de tous les
massacres commis au nom de la
civilisation occidentale
et puis aussi genova genoa 0-1 qui
revenait sur les événements de gênes en
2001 vous souvenez trois cent mille
personnes dans les rues qui criait haut
et fort un autre monde est possible
vous savez c'est qu'il a qui a étendu
par terre sur le sol
c'est carlo giuliani mort le 20 juillet
la première réelle icône de la rébellion
nikon morbide puisqu'il est mort tout au
bout la mort et puis plus rien bon comme
je crois que dans ce monde il n'y a plus
ni justice ni écouté ni solidarité née
juste préjudice ni risque gratis plus
que des artifices plus que dépenser lice
des exclus et de l'exclusif des preuves
des justificatifs et puis surtout
surtout un l'état social actif souvent
en tant qu'artiste je me pose la
question quelle est l'attitude adéquate
à voir ne doivent pas refuser produire
ce monde mérite il met production en
toute humilité
combien sommes-nous si égoïste à trouver
des solutions pour que vraiment est un
sens le mot d'émancipation dans mon nom
la rébellion celle qui fait que je suis
le roi comme dans la jungle le lion ce
nom qui fait deux mois que je ne suis ni
un enfant ni un homme au plus tôt au
moins un peu de tous les hommes
écorchée vive c'est certain je fais du
mieux pour traîner ma carcasse d'humain
dans mon nom la rébellion à la mémoire
des massacres et des déportés des
fusillés des victimes de pogroms de
toutes ces vies qu'on gomme pour que des
intérêts qui nous dépasse puisse
toujours garder leur place
pour toutes ces raisons et pour 1000
encore dans mon nom la rébellion
j'imprime encore des rimes sur le sillon
carla
tout pragmatisme désabusé façon réaliste
j'aimerais pouvoir être optimiste mais
je ne suis pas un lampiste
désolé je ne suis même plus idéaliste
partout partout les marchands d'armes en
embuscade sur tous les fronts en piste
les entendez-vous seulement cessons de
guerre ils sont bien là mes soeurs et
frères
partout la furie et le faire leurs
guerres longues guerres nominaux là où
cela on lire sur leur guerre lors guère
l'homme nos larmes nouveau là où leurs
chars leur girl ornières leur mort
ok tout sauf le pré les prêts sont dans
la tourmente la pression augmente ça pue
les années 30 il te faudra pour qui mens
et ça le fera mais ce que tu me demandes
géopolitique mondiale et rock de ce pic
de taille
ça va en masse est sévère mais sky puis
d'affaires de détail mais deux rondes de
sky qui en moi
les huit ans rêve elle travaille
d'arrache-pied quitte à sacrifier
lâchera en premier les politiques puis
les banques et la situation est critique
et cette crise se précise
à la veille de la troisième la tension
est le thème et le risque est multiple
sens-tu c dans l'air ça sent
sans la guerre ça génère du fric ça des
causes et des effets économiques quoi
être optimiste aveugle et sourd comme ce
droit de l'hommiste analyses en temps
m'ont dit ce qu on qualifie de
complaintes aux théories et puis ensuite
par l'ong la libye ou bien encore de la
syrie où bien des précédents pirates en
somalie
souvent les mêmes faiseurs de guerre les
états unis tout texte à siegen en vente
libre
bientôt la suppression à tout autant en
toute heure et en foot en puissance de
feu et technologies la danse de feu et
microbiologie du gaz du pétrole mam et
l'économie
que deviendront judiciaire en afrique
guitare par tout l'occident et la
colonie à ce sujet tabou ouah ouah
naseaux nightmare renouvin ce tournoi
tri another nightmare newman story
moi
merci alors je me rends compte que je
vous ai pas montrer mon magnifique
t-shirt circonstances je trouve donc
pour conclure je voudrais simplement
dire que je n'ai pas les réponses à mes
propres interrogations mais que en tout
cas je suis je suis vraiment sincèrement
convaincu que la créativité populaire
c'est une des clés pour changer le cours
et l'ordre des choses et je voudrais
vous souhaiter à toutes et tous dans les
semaines qui arrivent de nombreuses
nuits de boue et puis aussi la légende
ne raconte t-elle pas que notre petite
belgique fut créée après un autre père à
qui aurait mal tourné
je vous remercie